vous venez toujours tout juste de sortir
du comité interministériel des villes
avec la première ministre ellisabeth
borne tout d'abord quel bilan est-ce que
vous vous en faites est-ce que vous êtes
satisfait ah je ne peux pas dire que je
suis satisfait on a eu une série de
mesures parfois des mesurettes assez
artificiels qui ont été annoncé et
grainé tout au long de 2 heures de prise
de parole des ministres alors je
regrette déjà un grand absent c'est les
habitants des quartiers politique de la
ville cet exercice qui se limite à un
échange entre des élus des
institutionnels et le gouvernement ne
répond pas aux attentes des habitants
des quartiers populaires c'est ma
conviction il y a eu quelques annonces
qui sont positives dont on se réjouit
avec les maires de l'association ville
et banlieu qui regroupe les quartiers
politiqu de la ville on a par exemple
des annonces autour de la généralisation
des cités éducatives qui permettront de
mettre plus de partenariat entre
l'écoles les villes l'État dans nos
territoires euh on a des annonces aussi
qui sont pour l'instant cosmétiques mais
Don on attend de voir si elles peuvent
porter sur le territoire pour lutter
contre la ghettoisation notamment le
fait d'attribuer des logements aux
familles les plus pauvres dans les
quartiers qui sont déjà les plus pauvres
ça contribue à ghettoiser encore nos
quartiers on espère pouvoir en sortir
mais il y a pas de mesure de rupture il
y a pas de souffle il y a pas une
ambition à la hauteur de nos attentes et
pour l'instant je ne vois pas les
ingrédients qui permettrai d'éviter les
situations que nous avons connu il y a
quelques mois avec l'explosion de colère
dans nos quartiers et à votre avis
quelle est aujourd'hui la première
urgence à prendre en compte ou peut-être
les premières urgence à prendre en
compte il y en a malheureusement
plusieurs le défi éducatif évidemment
tant qu'on a 100000 enfants qui sortent
du système scolaire en étant
déscolarisés sans diplôme qui ne sont
pas accompagnés à partir de 16 ans et
bien on continuera de produire de la
vulnérabilité de la fragilité de l'échec
de la frustration du ressentiment et de
la colère chez une partie de notre
jeunesse donc réussir à être capable de
lutter contre le décrochage et contre
l'échec scolaire mais dès plus jeune âge
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut amplifier
et renforcer la question de l'emploi
aussi évidemment un sujet majeur il faut
pouvoir apporter des emplois dans ces
quartiers permettre des débouchés y
compris pour ceux qui n'ont pas
forcément des grand diplôme et il faut
aussi à mon sens résoudre ce problème de
la mixité si on continue à avoir des
villes qui se spécialisent dans
l'accueil de la pauvreté et qui voit 60
70 80 % de leur population être en
situation de relative pauvreté avec des
logements sociaux concentrés toujours
dans les mêmes quartiers toujours dans
les mêmes villes et bien on générera
toujours nos propres malheurs on peut
pas avoir des villes riches où les
riches vivent entre eux des villes
pauvres ou les pauvres vivent entre eux
ça c'est un défi que la France doit
relever mais ça demande plus que
quelques mesurettes annoncé un vendredi
matin et à l'issue du comité Catherine
arénou a dit qu'elle continuerait
d'espérer quelle est-vous aujourd'hui
votre état d'esprit nonous on n pas le
choix parce que vous savez la différence
entre les membres du gouvernement et et
les élus locaux c'est que nous on est au
contact quotidien avec la population si
nous on désespère la République est à
genoux donc on continuera non seulement
d'espérer mais d'agir d'agir sur le
terrain avec des solutions qu'on invente
localement et qui parfois inspirent les
gouvernements et puis aussi d'exiger et
d'être attentif exigeant vis-à-vis des
pouvoirs publics pour que l'ensemble des
ministères l'ensemble de ce qu'on
appelle le droit commun mette les moyens
nécessaire dans nos quartiers je
rappelle que en matière d'éducation en
matière de sécurité en matière de
justice plusieurs rapports ont établi le
fait que dans nos quartiers il y a moins
de moyens de l'État donc il faut au
moins garantir le même les mêmes moyens
pour tous les habitants de notre pays et
nous localement on restera disponible
pour inventer des solutions et les
mettre en re